foreign
most unexpected aspects of locism is
that it's constantly teaching us new
racial slurs that we never knew existed
and our racial slur vocabulary increased
yet again this week when the woke police
became outraged at Chris Curtis for
calling Mina kimes a nip quote unquote
now this immediately raises some
questions like who is Chris Curtis and
who is Mina kimes and what the hell is a
nip
I have no idea who any of these people
are or what the word is supposed to mean
and I suspect that most of the people
outraged or pretending to be outraged
were similarly Clueless
but just because they had no idea what
was going on or what was said or who
said it or who they said it to or about
or why that would not stop them from
being deeply traumatized by the
situation whatever the situation is
exactly so let's try to sort through
this earlier this week
a Sports Talk radio host on WEEI in
Boston jokingly called Mina kimes who is
apparently an ESPN sports analyst
um he said that she's one of his
favorite nips
now the joke was made in the context of
a conversation about little miniature
bottles of liquor which are also
apparently referred to as nibs I didn't
know that either
um here's that moment
so begs the question top five nips uh oh
yes that's a great one uh because I
think is number one or two screwball
also up there probably go Mina kimes and
Fireball Fireball
the McGillicuddy though but do you like
the purple or the root beer
now Curtis has since clarified that um
he meant to make the joke about actress
Mila Kunis but he said Mina kimes and he
also said that his comment was
um sophomoric and sexist which clearly
indicates that his intention was to make
a boob joke okay it was a nips pun That
was supposed to be a reference to
breasts
and even without this clarification that
that already seems pretty obvious from
the context
but unluckily for Curtis it turns out
that nip is also an obscure slur for
Japanese people last used you know
sometime around World War II
I have never in my life even one single
time ever heard that term used in
reference to Japanese people most of us
have never heard it
oh and by the way uh Mina kimes isn't
even Japanese she's Korean so so we're
left with two possibilities here okay
two possibilities
either
this radio host intentionally decided to
commit career suicide by knowingly using
an archaic anti-japanese slur last
uttered in 1945 during the Battle of Iwo
Jima in reference to a Korean sports
reporter or
he was just trying to make a dumb boob
joke
those are the two potential explanations
here
and it's quite obvious which one is the
most plausible but in these sorts of
situations the most plausible
explanation is rarely the most useful to
the victimhood narrative so the outrage
mob got to work pretending to believe
that this was an attack on Asian people
pretending to even know that the word
was a slur to begin with pretending to
be offended pretending to have been
somehow deeply injured by an
off-the-cuff remark made by a radio host
that no one's ever heard of about
another media personality no one's ever
heard of there were calls for Curtis to
be fired there were condemnations being
issued announcements ESPN spoke out
other sports media personalities chimed
in the whole circus of offendedness
commenced
the next day as expected Curtis issued a
groveling apology begging forgiveness
from those who were hurt
and he was then set off to sit in time
out and think about what he'd done this
of course is not enough for the
self-motoring idiots who are pretending
to care about this as this local media
report shows they still intend to milk
this for whatever it's worth watch well
the Boston sports radio host is off the
job tonight after using a racial slur to
describe an Asian-American ESPN reporter
weei's Chris Curtis says he's been
suspended for a week wbz's Laura hafley
shows us his apology and what made his
comment so hurtful
I just want to pause there for a moment
because uh because I I mean like I don't
mean to spoil this but I can tell you
what made his comment so hurtful and
that is um nothing
makes them hurtful because nobody was
hurt by them see there are two
categories of people when it comes to
situations like this in the first
category there are normal well-adjusted
human beings with lives to live and more
important things to think about and
worry about and those of us in that
category we don't have the time or
energy or inclination to be offended or
hurt by some dumb offhanded joke made by
some guy on some radio station somewhere
in the other category are desperate
maladjusted pathetic ridiculous losers
who have nothing interesting going on in
their lives and have achieved nothing
and will never achieve anything and who
live for the opportunity to play the
victim waiting for someone to trip up
and you know say the wrong thing so they
can swarm and feast like piranhas
devouring a wounded goat wading across a
river but the people in that category
they're not hurt either quite the
opposite they're excited they're
thrilled they're like ravenous with
Hunger ready to devour their next victim
they're incredibly grateful that they've
been given another fake grievance
so nobody is hurt not one person on the
planet is hurt that is who is Hurt No
One not one person anywhere
okay let's continue
a ban on miniature liquor bottles was
proposed Monday by Boston City councilor
Ricardo Arroyo garnering attention from
Neighbors and local media Outlets
including the Greg Hill radio show on
WEEI the show's hosts were discussing
the ban using the nickname for the
airplane-sized bottles when producer
Chris Curtis appeared to referred to an
Asian-American ESPN journalist Mina
kimes in a racist manner it dragged her
into a controversy
through no fault of her own uh regarding
a slur and her race Curtis was suspended
by WEEI I want to apologize for the
stupid lame attempt at a joke is it ever
clever to to be clever you know to be
clever at the expense of somebody's
identity Professor David Howell teaches
Japanese history at Harvard so it's
really very much a term that was used
during World War II to refer to the
Japanese when they were the enemy it's a
classroom or
um on the air
using a term
almost you know makes it sound like it's
okay to use the term WBZ reached out to
the chair of the Massachusetts aapi
commission Dr Gary Chu let's not go back
to the past and perpetuate hate
especially aapi hate which has been on
the rise not only in the U.S but also in
Massachusetts in the city of Boston Dr
Chu hoping for accountability from the
radio host and more representation
moving forward anytime we can denounce
things like that uh we'll help we're
working to see to talk about all these
issues providing resources to elevate
the messages of what is going on so that
everyone understands the diversity of
the Asian American popular Asian
American and Pacific Islander
populations we did reach out to ESPN who
called the comments hateful and
extremely offensive we also reached out
to Odyssey the owner of WEEI they did
not immediately give back to us in
Brighton Laura hafley WBZ News
it's not really the point but uh just
just one note is that banning the small
bottles of liquor is a really stupid
idea to begin with uh because if you do
that doesn't just mean people will buy
bigger bottles of liquor like what do
you think I I get the ideas because
people buy those little bottles it's
like if if you're if you're buying a
little bottle of liquor you're either an
alcoholic a college student not that
those two things are mutually exclusive
or you're on an airplane
um so it's really it's really uh it it
also actually by the way that that also
applies to if you're if you're buying
any kind of liquor at all or you're
consuming any kind of liquor at all
before like four o'clock in the
afternoon again you're either a college
student an alcoholic or you're on an
airplane but anyway you bet you ban the
small ones and so is that going to make
all the alcoholics say well guess I'm
not drinking any more liquor no now they
just buy bigger bottles and drink those
anyway so
but that's not the food over there
this is why you never apologize to these
people you never apologize to them
because this is who you are apologizing
to this is who the people you saw in the
video this is who you're bending the
knee to these are the people whose feet
you are kissing these two guys that you
just saw right there it's always these
guys
and people just like them okay they are
representative of who you are groveling
to you've got an insufferable college
professor in an ugly shirt with a smarmy
grin on his face looking down his nose
at you and telling you which words
you're allowed to use and which you
aren't allowed to use
it's not okay to say that well we don't
want people to have the impression that
it's okay to say that word it's not okay
to say that word because I say so
and then the other dude some useless
empty-headed bureaucrat with a doctorate
in self victimization on some pointless
commission that does nothing at all
whose own entire purpose is to justify
its existence by looking for things to
complain about this this is entirely
perfunctory right for both of them their
hearts aren't even in it you can tell
especially the last guy there
you know that guy it's like he he
couldn't even he couldn't even pretend
to actually think that this matters okay
and he's well we need uh diversity we
need to raise awareness of diversity and
so people will know about diverse uh
diversity
they don't believe what they're saying
they don't care they're just Petty
tyrants looking for an opportunity to
impose themselves on other people
this goes for the two guys in the clip
and everybody else in the outrage mob
because that's the thing about the
outrage mob there isn't much actual
outrage to be found in it
it's all for show
which is why as I've been shouting for
years
and as I myself have lived by this is
not something I'm telling other people
to do that I won't do but you must never
apologize to them no matter what
you must never apologize to them
say whatever you want to these people
just never say you're sorry
but Chris Curtis did Apologize so I
cannot save him even if I wanted to
instead I could only say that everybody
involved in this situation is today
canceled
and I'll do it for this portion of shows
and move over to the members block you
become you can become a member today by
using Code wall should check out for two
months for you on all annual plans hope
to see you there if not talk to you on
Monday Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]